[Music]
staging a show at the Edinburgh Fringe
is often a leap of faith but flip
Fabrique show is exceeding expectations
blending acrobatics with dance slapstick
with skating and parkour with piano
music the Canadian troupe is reinventing
circus
[Music]
it's always circus circus' is so vast
that you can end up playing with a mic
and juggling with it
oh it's circus but wait a minute teaches
the theatre ages danced and he was
sucking while he was doing it so he's
again doing theater while dancing and
there's music but then he does juggling
so we call it circus mixing art forms is
also an evidence at Edinburgh Botanic
Gardens where there's a multi-sensory
walk inspired by the sights sounds and
scientific study of the flow country
Scotland's peat bogs trees breathe and
sing
[Music]
transporting visitors to another world
we've commissioned nine artists who have
all been inspired by the flow country in
foreign art and Keith ness and
Sutherland which is in the north of
Scotland so they've all spent a variety
of time between three days some as long
as 18 months up there they worked with
scientists based in the flow country and
that's been the inspiration for all the
works that you see in the gardens
Edinburgh is the perfect environment for
artists to experiment with new
technologies this is a sonic umbrella
it's given to each visitor and plays the
sound of birdsong and original piano
music it also comes in handy when the
weather plays up one American company is
making live cinema using actors
projectors and 500 shadow puppets to
recreate the story of Frankenstein an
eccentric orchestra plays a haunting
soundtrack with some instruments
controlled by robotics these
cutting-edge pieces are playing well
with audiences in Edinburgh breaking the
mold and creating art that refuses to be
defined Charley Angela al Jazeera
Edinburgh